Lâche ce lecteur de DVD Gillou!
Echec et mat!
Fini les larcins!
C’est la fin des …
Attendez mais les mecs vous vous êtes trompé, c’est l’inverse normalement.
J’ai pas fait gaffe.
Game Over!
Ohh! Mais vous faites quoi là?
On est venu vous filez un coup de main?
Mais vous êtes pris pour qui?
Vous pensez qu’on a besoin de vous les mecs?
Quand même un peu nan?
Vous êtes classe hin… mais c’est pas super efficace quoi.
Ok.
vous êtes venu cherché la merde en fait c’est ça?
Nan nan nan mais c’est juste que ça fait 1000ans que vous courrez après un gars
donc au bout d’un moment, ça devenait ridicule.
T’as dit quoi là?
On va te montrer qui est ridicule.
On fait quoi on les attend?
J’ai un peu la dalle moi j’irai bien manger un truc quoi.
Vas y. Ouais.
On revient.